[Music]
who is the more talented quarterback
russell wilson or matthew stafford more
talented so that it's up to the user how
you define talent okay
well why don't we have the user be steve
palozzolo who's the co-host of pro
football focus he spends his life
analyzing the numbers here and we have
seattle hosting the rams coming up
tonight steve the most
more talented quarterback matthew
stafford and russell wilson jr iii
yeah it really does come down to how you
define talent and i usually lean toward
better football player because
talent has to show up on the field so
i'd go russell wilson uh because all the
the talents that he has includes winning
from the pocket winning from outside the
pocket accuracy decision making like
decision making's talent isn't it i mean
that's that's part of it so uh i think a
lot of times we lean toward physical
tools and i'll always say stafford has
three games a year
where he looks like he's the most
talented quarterback in the nfl it's
like man if i could bottle that up and
multiply it by five
this is a hall of famer but
consistency also matters i think too so
stafford does special things but russ i
would say i'd give them the edge there
why are you not all in on the seahawks
have you labeled them
pretenders
uh no i mean i think i think their
defense is still a major question mark
they've got the ninth worst coverage
grade uh by pff standards here uh
they're not they're not challenging
passes enough they had a nice week last
week against the 49ers but the defense
is still a major question mark and the
offense it's a new offense it's uh you
know shane waldron comes in and
it's a little top heavy right now so
that when they when they create those
explosive plays they're great it's it's
all the other plays in the middle they
just haven't been as efficient as
they've been in the past i think they'll
figure it out but i think there's
there's still some growth for uh for
seattle well handicapped the nfc west
right now because
you're looking at arizona and i was on
arizona's bandwagon last year and then
uh i i was the last one on arizona's
bandwagon
everybody had fallen off should we be
high why should we be high on the
cardinals
they are and first off kylo mari you
know you don't always have quarterbacks
just get better every year it's not like
a madden game where you just add a
couple points overall it doesn't work
that way but uh it worked like that for
josh allen and it looks like it's
working like that for tyler murray it's
not common but uh kyler's getting better
every single year and he is
all of a sudden arizona also has an
incredible group of playmakers just the
ability to move christian kirk into the
slot as an explosive threat uh max
williams i think if max williams was in
another system he's a top 10 tight end
and you know they threw a seam route to
him for a touchdown the other day
they've got guys to throw to beyond
deandre hopkins so i think that's great
kyler's development his ability to throw
the ball over the middle of the field
which he wasn't doing his first couple
seasons and then he's just got those
those two or three freak plays per game
where it's like hey try to tackle me i'm
going to scramble or i'm going to
scramble to throw and you can't stop it
so kyler's got all of that going for him
the playmakers are great defense might
be over achieving a touch right now and
that'd be my only concern i think with
arizona would be that secondary let me
go back to the rams because they have
led with their defense is that defense
still
formidable top five top three best in
football
yeah i mean it's again it's one of those
things we study a lot here at pff where
if you are a team banking on defense
year over year it's just it's tough to
do because a lot of
a lot of defensive success is based off
who you play so you know the rams were
as good as it gets at a limiting
explosive play so you know the 20 games
prior to week three when they faced the
bucks they'd only given up 78 explosive
plays you know 15 plus yards that's
about four per game that's incredible
today's nfl to limit offenses to four
per game is outstanding over the last
two weeks the rams they played the bucks
and they played the cardinals two
explosive offenses they gave up eight
and a half per game so more than double
so it's one of those things if the rams
are only going to bank on their defense
going forward they're in trouble luckily
they have a good offense but their
defense has started to show some holes
right from last year and i don't know if
it's the brandon staley factor or
whatever it might be
but the rams will have a good defense
not as dominant as last year i think
that was predictable and they'll have to
rely on that offense continuing to be
one of the most efficient in the nfl i
know you study every play you guys grade
every play i said i would not put justin
fields in there uh given the upcoming
schedule that is okay so they just got
through with detroit now you have vegas
in vegas green bay
you have tampa you have san francisco
pittsburgh's defense baltimore's defense
and then you get detroit again what's
going to change here in the next six or
seven weeks steve that you need to have
justin fields in there instead of andy
dalton
nothing's changed except probably a
little bit of outside pressure i mean my
whole thing with with fields and any
rookie quarterback is the bears have to
make the best decision for justin fields
not for 2021 but for 22 23 and 24.
what's the best decision
for his development and and i don't
think there's a clear cut play him and
let him take his lumps or sit him like
mahomes or like aaron rodgers i don't
think there's a clean answer there but i
respect teams who stick with it right
and say look we're gonna sit him or
we're gonna play him with fields there
is the fear of what happened in the
browns game one net passing yard getting
sacked nine times not and that wasn't
all just play calling despite the
narratives that's not all matt and
aggie's fault it was the offensive line
was trash you know the browns were
incredible miles garrett was a freak in
that game and justin fields had some
issues holding the ball and not seeing
things right so uh
that part of it is the scary thing if he
has another game where he gets sacked
seven eight nine times does that affect
his long-term development so that would
be the question on fields the raiders
passwords is our number one graded pass
rush and they're doing it with a
four-man rush so i think we'll learn a
lot this week but uh it's a tough
situation because i don't think the bear
should be thinking about winning now
they got to be thinking about what's
best for fields long term yeah i that's
where i am that i know that i mean
patrick mahomes didn't start his first
year because they you know they had alex
smith and they were coming off i think a
12-4 season if they were getting rid of
alex smith and they were eight and eight
mahomes probably would have started
aaron rodgers didn't want to sit it just
they weren't going to sit down bradford
like we make it seem like boy they they
had this strategy in place
you know they
they didn't really have a strategy in
place it was like we got mahomes we'll
move on from uh you know uh alex and
then you know eventually farve is going
to get old and we'll put in aaron
rodgers i just don't understand this
philosophy of put justin fields in there
like hey we got to see the fans in the
media like we got to see something new
we know what andy dalton is we need hope
here and it feels like they're kind of
banking on hey here's your hope go out
there and try to survive
yeah i mean that's the thing like if
you're the bears organization you
certainly shouldn't be making decisions
based off the fans in the media or we
know or just by andy dalton in general i
will stick with that i don't care what
andy dalton does if your plan if you
think justin fields has to sit 17 games
fine if you think he needs to sit until
he gets it whatever gets it means at
practice then that should be the problem
you know like whenever you think he's
ready whether it's week one 10 or 17 or
18 it doesn't matter just stick with it
so uh it does feel like their their
hands being forced a little bit based
off of the situation steve palazzolo he
is the co-host of pro football focused
nfl podcast
do you have power rankings at pff
uh we do i don't have them right in
front of me but yeah they're they are
over there at pff.com all right i could
try to best dig them up real quick who's
who do you think's the uh the top-rated
like the analytics i know cardinals are
the last undefeated team
yeah so
it certainly wouldn't be based off of
record i mean we still have the chiefs
as the as the top team and the way we do
a lot of our power rankings are like if
you played these teams on a neutral
field what are against an average team
what are they going to be favored by and
the chiefs are favored by seven points
against an average team on a neutral
field that that's the number one team
because our power rankings are taking in
not just four games but everything that
we know so it's
it's the chiefs the bucks and then the
bills are our top three teams so we
haven't come far off of the chiefs are
still legit
the bucks are still legit even though
they you know things haven't been
perfect for either team through four
games and then the bills they've they've
risen through the rankings just a little
bit because we their defense is far
better than we expected plus you know
their offense is is still really good
led by josh allen uh what's pff think of
dallas's defense
it's definitely better this year i think
the you know travon diggs has five
interceptions in four games and you know
it's tough to maintain uh you know
turnover rate so to speak so that's one
thing that could regress but i think
dallas last year at this time that it
was busted coverages left and right and
big plays they've done a much better job
of just not losing games right and it
has coincided with their running attack
being a little bit better whether that
is causation i don't know but the
defense has been better and all they
needed to be was not a disaster because
i think that offense is fantastic with
dak and all those playmakers we have a a
new
designation mclovin do you want to give
this to steve yeah is there such a thing
as wow plays from a quarterback
so i i created uh a stat uh with using
the pff numbers just called big time
throws so it might we could do this with
the run game too but a big time throw
for us is you know because we're grading
every player on every play and we have
levels of grading it's all of our
highest graded plays yeah but btt
doesn't sound as good as wow look i'm
not the best at naming stuff i don't
want to try to help you you can take
this
you can you take pff can have wow plays
you want wow plays yeah instead of
trademarks
i mean nobody cares big as a big time
throw no it's a wow play wow play means
it could be you know zeke elliot running
for 50 yards
yeah for us it would be you know we we
grade everybody on point five increments
anything plus one or better at any
position could be a wow play all right
i'll run that up the chain and see if we
could get because we could absolutely
pull that out we got that come on you're
sitting around and you're going out hey
guys what do you think about wow plays
you don't even have to give us credit
like a bunch of guys a bunch of nerds
sitting around you know looking at game
film i mean not he's gonna take big-time
throws to the moon and you just you know
no no no no yeah take it leave it there
give it to elon musk let him take it up
there and leave it up there like wow
plays
wow place we'll do it all right all
right great to talk to you steve have a
good weekend thank you bud thank you
guys steve palazzolo